we continue our series issues that
matter with a closer look at the
Republican health care bill and the
questions about cost and coverage in a
letter to Congress the American Hospital
Association said it is concerned about
the plans effort to restructure the
Medicaid program the group decided quote
we cannot support the American Health
Care Act in its current form dr. Stephen
Corwin is the president and CEO of New
York Presbyterian also remember the
American Hospital Association New York
Presbyterian by the way is one of the
nation's biggest health care providers
it is six place on US News and World
Report's the best Hospital list so
they're doing something right over there
New York Presbyterian serves more than
four million patients every year in dr.
Corwin joins us at the table thank you
so much for thanks for having me thanks
we're very glad that you're here so your
group said cannot support it in its
current form what concerns you most well
I think that the Medicaid expansion in
rolling back the Medicaid expansion as
of 2020 is going to create a real
problem how much of your work the
patients who we represent of our
patients are Medicaid well and that in
remember one out of every three new york
city residences is on medicaid and
you've got a lot of people on Medicaid
in Republican states as well so this is
a big deal eight hundred billion dollars
is going to come out of the Medicaid
program over the next ten years and that
contributes to that deficit reduction
that that you talked about Gail and
that's a big big issue because a lot of
people are not going to be insured and
the Budget Office says now 24 more
million people will not be insured how
does that affect your Hospital
specifically look I think that we're
about taking care of patients and I
think that we have to as a country
decide is health care or right or is it
a privilege if it's a right then we've
got to insure everybody and if we want
to ultimately control the cost of health
care you've got to insure people
so therefore what is the fundamental
miss assumption on the part of this bill
the fundamental miss assumption is that
you need to subsidize people more and
you need to keep the individual mandate
otherwise you cannot have a functioning
insurance market point number one point
number two is they've got to have a
mandate that forces people to have
insurance absolutely
just like car insurance car insurance
property insurance
you need young healthy people who are
paying premiums in to offset the costs
of other people who are so they abolish
that so what is the other assumption
that's wrong you got to take care of
poor people in the states that didn't
expand Medicaid you have to earn less
than six thousand dollars a year to
qualify for Medicaid for a family of
three now as a country I think we've got
to come to grips with that
I believe in a public-private
partnership you have to have commercial
insurance and you have to have Medicare
and Medicaid let's come together and
figure out how to do this this bill
absolutely does not do this but the the
power behind reforming and repealing the
Affordable Care Act the conservative
movement is that this was a mandate a
burden on small and medium-sized
businesses to pay for health care the
question still remains who's going to
pay for it our tax payer is going to pay
for it in higher taxes or businesses
going to pay for it what's the answer
there and is there any fix in terms in
this bill look Nora you're absolutely
right the cost of health care in this
country is too high doctors physicians
everybody happens it has to really focus
on getting the cost down but having said
that you got to ensure people and I
think that by not ensuring people the
cost of health care is going to continue
to go up the AMA the eh-eh-eh doctors
hospitals all back to the Affordable
Care Act Obamacare and under the promise
that premiums would start to slow down
premiums have skyrocketed premiums have
skyrocketed a couple of things happen
first you have lack of competition in
certain markets secondly you didn't have
enough young healthy people that's the
point to it young people have to be buy
insurance if they're not they're not
gonna be a system to take care of older
people but Laura nor let me flip it
around to you for a second what's gonna
happen with less subsidies and what the
CBO has said is premiums are gonna go up
in the short run
the only reason premiums go down over
the long run is older sicker patients
will opt out of the program because they
cannot afford it yeah there has to be a
fundamental shift people don't want to
pay for health care they don't want to
pay people will pay for all kinds of
things
it's a car they'll pay for house
insurance house insurance and and it
because in the past the system was
always that your employer if you had a
good employer provided your health care
plan
well employer-based health insurance is
the bulwark of the system 170 million
people get that so what you're talking
about was Medicare and Medicaid that's
another hundred and fifty million people
and then what do you do in the
individual insurance market how many are
in that market right now it's less than
the CBO projected that's part of what
the Republicans are claiming about the
CBO report but part of that is because
people didn't really insist on the
individual mandate there was a Supreme
Court challenge on it etc I gotta say
this guy's I went to New York Hospital
for my surgery and dr. Girardi and
Lerman and and Blumenthal took really
good care of me I really appreciate that
lucky well we appreciate the compliment
it's your you're a terrific show I've
got to tell you that my wife watches you
every day so she's a big fan your wife
has excellent taste thank you for taking
such good care of Charlie
yeah and really smart discussion I think
you should do more of this we have been
on our issues that matter turns out it's
complicated
[Laughter]